we're gonna talk next about a
documentary that is all about a woman
who falls in love get married and has a
baby and it's cleaning up at Film Awards
around the world although there's
something different about this
documentary all of that happens in the
middle of the conflict in Syria right at
the heart of the city of Aleppo the
documentary is called for summer take a
look
[Applause]
hi - Elam Solomon Lord
I had an empanada yeska be forcibly
available
[Music]
come on so MA
I've seen it it truly is a remarkable
documentary the co-directors of that
film wide al-khatib and Ed watts join me
now hello wow this is very much your
film it's interesting isn't it
you start the film in Aleppo when all of
this is just starting and halfway
through you find out you're about to
become a mother and I was like I wasn't
there for two kids and like I feel just
now it's very poor so a little bit hard
for me touch they place where I was
really and especially on but now in the
UK where I feel that this is my second
home now it's interesting at the very
start of the film when you give birth to
summer and all of this is erupting
around you you ask what have I brought
you into can you ever forgive me and
that's a question that you wrestle with
throughout the film because you want to
stay in Aleppo and record what's
happening but at the same time you're
getting married you're having a baby and
having to consider your family yeah it's
more about like every Syrian has that
thoughts in his mind about like did I'm
doing the right thing or not even people
who left they have the same question
every day about I'm doing I I am am i
doing the right things even here now I'm
having that question every day
but just you can't really know what the
right thing to do you can't know if I've
stayed there like that's what going for
worse or it will be like they hope that
we all dream off of the freedom and the
dignity and the justice
Edward attracted you to making this film
because it really is a different look at
serious through the eyes of a woman a
young woman you know getting married
having a baby there really is something
so different about this documentary and
you know a lot of people who are in
Syria don't want the world to look away
so this must have been an attractive
proposition for you in terms of taking a
different look at the conflict
definitely I mean I think what is
incredible about wide story and hamza
and what she's managed to capture in our
footage because she filmed it all over
five years was a side of syria that we
really don't hear about in this country
and in the west you know so often
everything that comes out of syria is
the context of terrorism or the refugee
crisis and I always wanted to make a
film that really brought out our shared
humanity that we have with Syrian people
and that's what you see in this film you
see people who are just like you there
are jokes in this film I mean people
don't expect there to be humor in a
conflict zone like this but there is and
that's the spirit of the Syrian people
something I think we can all relate to
and I think that's what gives the film
its power and what what we really see in
this film is the slow realization of
what exactly is happening you speak in
the film about remembering the day that
the peaceful protests turned into
something more sinister and we go on
that emotional journey with you
yeah it's really for us as Syrian the
fact that the first two years was for us
something we all we all wanted and what
happened everything happened after this
was all because of the violence that the
Assad regime and then later on the
Russian were trying to do with all the
like big weapons that against us
everything I've did and the film was
just a normal life in Syria and
unfortunately this is still happening
until now now it's three years like ago
what that's what happened and now you've
seen the same exactly picture coming
from adlib the last era of the regime
control he really did put a human face
and human feelings this conflict in
Syria because you know most people's
knowledge of the conflict will be
through news channels like ourselves and
you know we talked to a lot of people in
Syria but what you do is you show that
your husband was one of the only doctors
to stay inside the city and help people
and you have personal loss you lost
friends along the way
who were trying to help people in the
city yeah we were so lucky that we save
survived and I feel just we survived to
tell the story now and going around the
world to tell people exactly what the
life looked like in Syria the film will
provide everyone who watching one hour
and a half of going there and training
the life there and filled that
experience exactly and only the main
thinks is like to remind everyone that
this is still happening yeah that's the
thing isn't it a yearand spokesman said
recently that the world have become numb
to the carnage in Syria after more than
eight years of war and you want to
reignite people's attention and interest
in what's going on exactly I mean I
think so many
people they look at Syria they don't
understand it it seems too complicated
seems like it's happening so far away
but I think what you see in this film is
you really see the truth of what
happened in the conflict why it started
why the violence grew to the levels that
it did and I hope that people you know
will re-engage and understand that
actually when you think about the effect
that for example the rise of Isis and
the refugee crisis have had on our own
politics you know we're all intimately
connected with the course of that
conflict and and as you talk about the
fact that you know a lot of
international norms that protected us
for example hospitals used to be
considered non-military targets well now
in Syria they're being targeted
systematically the use of chemical
weapons the same thing and why do you
come from East Aleppo to East London
you're now working in in the news
industry in the UK with a specialist you
know interesting what's going on in
Syria but this was for summer how is she
how is your daughter she's a good yeah
okay like she's so practical girl and we
were as I mentioned like so lucky that
we were survived and we were like just
have the lecture to be out and to be
here now well we appreciate you coming
in to tell us about for summer the
documentary film which is an incredible
watch it's out on general release this
Friday thank you so much thank you talk
to us all about it thank you